on was led by Mike Scott and Shelvin
Mack the Wizards have not been able to
get back close enough food rounding
yield scores inside 13 in the game for
Beals Pierce cathuria that's cool more
chat is here for the offensive for peds
Peter 85
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they floated to the rim the basket
you got to be kidding me
how about that
perform hand
I don't know who drew that one up but
that was nice Tannas streaking into the
paint bob boubker feel at the other end
to rip away the block and the
continuation all by Bradley he'd fast
and furious on areas 7 moment opening in
theaters this Friday what a terrific
play and you notice he went along the
side of the shooter a right-handed
shooter Bob good day
that's Grants Pass picked off and go
ahead to peel the checks
great pass by Paul Pierce just threw it
out there and let Bradley Beal allow him
to catch up with it so he'd never had to
break stride
[Applause]
dealer shot that saw him end up on his
backside
Bradley feel Wizards it's been up and
down for Bradley Beal today absorbing
the content and that is number six on
Kyle Lowry not a great day for the
Raptors
Toxie
we lawyers
[Applause]
the presence of mine appealed and no the
clock is going down and getting a
friendly roll and he tree down kick-out
here's the breeze sure
[Applause]
get to the head sure
[Applause]
there we go water get today vo on a
check
[Applause]
quickly the wall wall measures feel it's
open for three
where is it Verizon Center and Bradley
Beal stroke is perfect sir
you do it all the way a good baseline
fake get Aldridge out of the picture he
has a clear look be fun to play against
and it's maddening doubt the card he'll
drop taxes by Sansa for Bradley Beal to
get the Wizards fans a little juice
Beale spins the other way now drives
reverse layup good what a shot by Beal
well he had to put a little extra spin
on it he was coming down but Bradley
Beal with a remarkable reverse layup
yeah he floated to the other side just
that sixth assist for John Wall Porter
takes it away and here's wall with
another great pass for being
Los Angeles on wall here comes Russell
[Applause]
once Bradley Taemin perfectly I wonder
if even Otto saw Bradley kind of pacing
himself so he'd make a real strong stab
at it
knocked-up hall has the steel coming
down court
Beal
[Applause]
here great body control moves around but
never lose the side of the basket
[Music]
Neil drives nice moves first plan how
about that what a great court cat gets
another one up ahead the law he's inside
even marcin Gortat for the Nifty block
here starts the break and then wall
revealed
with dynasties tell me who's gonna watch
the 20th performance of Neil Diamond did
you know that's great got it stick it
out baby we gotta do it
Sweet Caroline outside nice catch by
feel wonderful what a shot by beat Ernie
Johnson
let's see if this shot which went in
it's good look at Washington closes out
on the 8th to run and deals got 18 a
game hide for the Wizards its download
from our Keith Mars nor their defeat in
last time picture - the vo but rival
Johnson and a great cam inside Bradley
Beal sin fans home Kevin this is how you
close the arena down and beautiful
posing routine you take it down the lane
late in the game you dunk on everybody
you look at the crowd and said I hope
you enjoyed my time at this arena behind
on fast-break points in the first
quarter in game 5 field drive in what a
reverse now that was a great move to get
open on a screen on the right side of
the floor six wood floor excellent now
this is an explosion to the
and up on the up besides although a Pope
turns it over the eighth of the game for
the Lakers would leave feed and bail
with the mammoth hammer tell you what on
a 13-2 run nothing like baptizing the
Pope Pele splits defenders hanging shot
is up and score the field goal he'll go
to the line drive in the game presented
by honda Bradley Beal yes give it the
Phoenix Suns their first lead since they
were up 2827 Sano down court but filled
with jumper off the glass is good what a
shot from Bradley Beal in Portland
Bradley Beal has 30 after three and the
Wizards go back up by one
[Music]
[Applause]
your chat deal gets free good job star
the field goal he'll go to the line
watch Austin Rivers he jumps to try and
blow up that handoff and that gives
Bradley Beal the free space to get back
door and how many times have we seen
this March and Bradley Beal two-man game
with John Wall out of the lineup work to
perfection all over the time line for
Beal being with a big slam on the
baseline that's the first team that
plays defense will win yep out of the
gates the first six minutes in this
quarter the Washington Wizards have been
that team and when you defend that leads
to this easy opportunities in transition
beautiful soaring dunk by Bradley Beal
to finish off that play you're right
Karen out Pele gets the steal takes the
shot goes at the buzzer that's a little
two-for-one action
great anticipation by Beal looks like
the two hesitated at first knowing that
Bradley field was lurking through it
anyway to the White House and the
perfect place in the time how about this
for a recovery for the Washington
Wizards they were horrible defensively
the entire hat feel behind his back gets
inside reverse slam how about that play
by Pratley peel our Honda Drive of the
game how about this moved here I so feel
this one's up and that's the Bradley
Beal
has just become the all-time leader in
three-point field goals made in
Washington Wizards franchise history
he's five of ten from long range with 29
points in the game Wizards need a 3-2
tie wall had it now he'll take the shot
give it up to be feels three-pointer
Bradley Beal ties it a selfless play by
John Wall he could have taken the three
excellent court awareness by John Wall
everyone runs toward him and leaves
Bradley Beal wide open from the top of
the key not the guy that you want to
leave wide open but further Wizards an
incredible play a clutch shot for mr.
Beal 25 points for Beal 5 of 7 from long
range 10 of 22 overall on the night
parted by Beal gets a screen from Newark
hich Miller drives puts up its block
tipped no good
go to overtime the wizards spring off
the hardwood and they all landed on
green and seeing this angle heel drives
and slams it in
[Applause]
his name on this one so far the
athleticism seconds in the quarter shot
clock is off Beale nice move gets inside
lays it up little left-handed scores
what a terrific play by Bradley field
shakin and bakin out of the glass
Andy Beal made a terrific move at the
end of the quarter nice aggressive play
from Bradley and to avoid the weak shot
Stephens will continue to do that if
it's a three-point margin
[Applause]
at 1:13 a perfect bounce back and the
Red Sea parts parts right for for the
layup if window Carter jr. 8 for 10
Robin Lopez 4 for 6 power another great
pass from Bryant's appeal with a vicious
finish honda drive of the game
Thomas Brian finds Bradley Beal and
Bradley Beal makes no mistake about this
he'll want to pass what a sequence slams
it in Bradley's complaining about being
pushed those familias Silva hard to see
on that angle Beal comes the other way
and slams it in Auto for three he'll for
three
friendly being with his sixth
three-pointer ties the game at 1:24 can
you believe that 40 points offensive
rebound at 8:42 and his tip right to him
it's gets the ball back field
contact scores to tie the game at 131
where's your stream feel splits
defenders was all the way and a big-time
slam for the all-star they've outscored
the wizards 13 to 2 chased out by Troy
brown nicely done feel strong for the
Slam by Bradley Beal over the top and
down the hatch
Beale steps back for three get Bradley
Beal hits it and we are tied at 1:21
waters shot by Beal Washington an
incredible play old toss Gibson's
momentum is going towards the basket
Bradley Beal with the step-back tying
the game five more minutes we'll take it
just his second three-pointer made
tonight two of eight that one was huge
[Applause]
ties the game at 1:13 with 2.4 seconds
to play for this
I mean running around the entire
possession and the shoddy old Swilley
takes is not easy at all there's two
Chicago Bulls players in the area you
could sheet Hopkins Romans inwards to
make that shot yep good pass by Jabari
now the you coming that's knocked away
by Dekker on a good boy Beale attacks
goes down
[Music]
going in there amongst the trees man
cero cheering Kyrie Irving on the court
is something special you know a guy like
Rose you that can play defense Kyrie may
have the best handles Bradley bill with
the handles strong finish inside that's
what he can do along with spacing that
floor what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content